One of the great signs is the beast
and the yuck and that's 1 big hairy beast
many scholars say
that this is the beast what Denny medaria
all that has long seen
on the deserted island where this year
today is chained
some scholars say something different
to lag value and million
in the Zutphen of the prophet
salla allaahoe alayhi WA sallam
has clearly come
that there is at the end of time
and that the beast will emerge
1 Big beast
and this beast will talk
with the people
the prophet salla allaahoe alayhi WA sallam she
as is stated in sahir muslim,
among others
he said of the great signs
is that the jam is coming and the sun is coming from the west
and that of battle art
that the beast will emerge
in other agah thief that should not arise in zachech
says this beast will talk to the humans
and also the people will brand
people will tag on their nose
so the muslims become very white and very beautiful
and the coffee gets 1 black tip
through which you will recognize
who is muslim
and it is beetle
all this in preparation for the fire